I don't really have no plans to talk
about this new Twilight trailer
whatsoever because I saw it and I was
like it's pretty much the same thing you
get the same notion out of this that you
got out of the last trailer oh she's a
vampire their happily ever after they
have a kid the Volturi are pissed and
now they need to fight them or recruit
other people to fight for him this
trailers pretty much the same as the
last trailer of course we have to start
out with Bella reading cue cards because
that's what she sounds like she's doing
my time as a human is over but I never
felt more alive yeah well you certainly
doesn't sound alive you sound bored
shitless as you make us feel what's
really funny about this is it shows the
chick from taken and she's all like
emotional about [ __ ] you know you can
see it in her eyes like she's tearing up
I have to report a crime
the Cohens they've done something
terrible so we go from that emotional
probably overacting to this total Tory
takes Vanessa Mason immortal child man
and the main premise in this movie is
just absurd to me they're like alright
if enough people knew the truth the
Volturi will listen to us so let's
recruit people from all corners of the
earth people we've never met before
research began looking for vampires in
the most remote corners of the world my
family's in danger I need your help
Jules upon this family out of nowhere
like hey how's it going um did I catch
you at dinner I did didn't I I'm really
sorry about that but you don't know me
I'm from Washington um can you help me
the whole vampire Illuminati is about to
take my daughter and kill her yeah you
really have no stake in it whatsoever
but it would mean a lot whatever
I'm pretty sure vampires from all
corners of the earth don't want to know
these boring people and they all have
different powers you know speed
waterbending and holy [ __ ] is that
Alexis Arquette I'm not actually gonna
say that that is the transsexual Alexis
Arquette but I'm just saying for
Morissette now she looks like Alexis RK
from that one image I'm sure if I see
her in the movie I'm gonna be like oh
she's hot [ __ ] I can't think that now
cuz I already said she looks like a
transsexual I think it's really exciting
when the trailers like every moment has
led to this
I'll never learn anybody are you did the
trailer just tell me that all of the
movies have led to this some chick
tucking her kid into bed now I do
believe that usually these Twilight
trailers show all the action and when
you watch the movie of life there's no
action it's just boring love [ __ ]
but I do believe this movie will not be
any more or less exciting than some
chick tucking her kid into bed not going
to knock him for false advertising no
bait and switch here and I really think
it'll be like that I think it'll be
something where it's like alright all
the vampires are there and it looks like
we're gonna throw down maybe a couple of
vampires do scrap but in the end they'll
be like hey listen let's talk about our
problems smell the chicks will be like
this so weren't that is what it is and
in the end we see the true teamwork
Edward grabs Bella and swings around
like a duel tech or something like that
that was a Chrono Trigger reference I
really apologize for using a Chrono
Trigger reference I should never have
done that I'll probably have to stand
trial for it in fact I'm gonna be
pushing for the death penalty because no
one should ever mention Chrono Trigger
in a twilight video not as a comparison
anyway so yeah in the end it's all the
same [ __ ] boring people bad actors
and a premise in a movie that doesn't
need to happen but it's finally over
best part about this trailer is it
already shows Bella leaf Edward
seriously not one scene bella tackles a
cougar Ella going for the Cougars that
was that was pretty funny alrighty why
did I make this video I was sitting
around and I was like I should probably
make a video about that trailer let's
just get that over with so the Twilight
Saga Breaking Dawn Part 2 does it look
any better for you now than it did
before if there's actually comments like
actually cut it yeah you're lying to me
in any case comment whatever you want
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
almost done folks hang in there
you
[Music]